[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde dont vous parlez des
territoires à la fois de la diversité
des territoires mais également des
fractures territoriales alors nous
habitons et nous vivons au sein de
territoires d'une formidable diversité
les métropoles bien sûr qu'ils
concentrent l'activité et les emplois la
population des villes moyennes qui se
développent et dont l'attractivité gagne
de nouvelles couches de population la
périphérie urbaine des villes dont le
développement laisse parfois à désirer
avec des violences sociales est ce qu'on
appelle la ruralité qui depuis alphonse
allais et sa prévision célèbre de
construire des villes à la campagne a
tendance à s'urbaniser si cette
diversité spatiale constitue un atout
naturel et touristique
la beauté et le charme français en
dépendent les difficultés liées à
l'harmonie sociale au pouvoir d'achat au
développement économique au mobilité et
aux services publics créent des
ségrégations diverses qui porte atteinte
au vivre ensemble et à la cohésion
nationale
nous allons nous pencher sur toutes ces
questions avec vous madame que je
présente et np skins qui est architecte
urbaniste directrice du puca le
laboratoire des territoires du ministère
de l'écologie gérard longuet vous êtes
sénateur de la meuse vous avez été
ancien ministre vous êtes président de
l'opecst sts l'office parlementaire des
choix scientifiques et techniques et j
présider une région pendant 12 ans et
vous avez présidé une région pendant 12
ans ont nommé toujours de citer tout un
cv quand il a été plein comme vous le
vôtre jacques lévy vous êtes géographe
et laurent davezies vous êtes professeur
au cnam
[Musique]
alors à propos des territoires nous
sommes abreuvés de chiffres sur les
territoires mais le récit territoriales
c'est d'abord une histoire liée à la
diversité des lieux à la variété des
populations comment peut-on qualifier en
deux mots un territoire nommé france ce
qui fait son unité
autour de sa diversité gérard longuet
ont la france est une construction
politique on a théorisé en particulier
au début du 20e siècle des frontières
naturelles pour justifier nos relations
avec certains voisins mais c'est une
construction politique qui est né du
bassin parisien qui est né de la très
forte la plus grande richesse agricole
qui a permis aux capétiens de
constituer de financer une armée et donc
de constituer un centre de pouvoir
après la construction territoriale
c'est une aventure
parlons de l'époque actuelle qui est
marqué par la technologie de production
le déclin de la place de l'agriculture
le déclin des industries de production
et de main d'oeuvre et le sort
formidable de la tertiarisation
qui touche très inégalement les
territoires alors nbsk il comment vous
arrivez
harmoniser diversité et unité parce
qu'on est on à la fois cette diversité
naturelle et il ya une unité
territoriale alors vous avez décrire les
différentes strates différentes briques
qui forment le territoire français mais
je pense qu'il faudrait éviter trois
grandes confusions qui sont peut-être un
peu des idées reçues des des idées trop
rapide la première c'est la confusion
entre la métropole et la métropolisation
en fait il ya des phénomènes de
métropolisation historique depuis à peu
près 40 ans de concentration des valeurs
de concentration d'un certain nombre de
fonctions dans des territoires est
derrière cette concentration un certain
nombre d'infrastructures notamment de
transport qui viennent conforter ses
effets de métropolisation qui sont
souvent liées à la compétition mondiale
ça veut pas dire que la métropole soit
exactement cette concentration les
métropoles ne sont pas que leur ville
centre elles sont finalement un camaïeu
de territoire avec des riches et des
pauvres c'est je pense la deuxième
confusion on a parlé souvent de france
périphérique un terme proposé par par un
amateur qui s'appelle guy lui en fait là
il ya une confusion aussi solide et où
la notion qu'il y aurait des territoires
riches et des territoires pauvres en
fait dans l'évier trop paul ya à la fois
des riches et des pauvres c'est même là
qui a les plus pauvres notamment dans
les quartiers de la politique de la
ville dans les quartiers les grosses
ensemble 1500 quartiers de la politique
de la ville c'est 40 % des gens en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté ces gens là
sont des urbains ils sont pas des ruraux
et ils sont donc dans ces territoires
pauvres des grandes métropoles
et puis la troisième confusion à mon
avis c'est celle qu'on peut faire une
autre fracture sociale et fracture
culturelle on a assez clairement et
c'est vrai dans tous les pays
occidentaux une
différence culturelle entre les
mondialisée entre guillemets et les
localiser et cette fracture se révèle
dans le territoire il n'est pas
nécessairement uniquement ou seulement
ou complètement une fracture sociale
alors laurent davezies et jacques levy
je vous lirai avec vous préciser cette
chose-là hannah arendt considère que de
la diversité on fabrique de l'unité est
ce que vous pensez qu au niveau des
territoires on a besoin de diversité
pour avoir une unité
lequel veut commencer jacques levy ou
d'ailleurs un arendt parle de l'espace
entre les gens qui est un élément de
diversité c'est à dire le fait qu' on
n'est pas tous se coller les uns contre
les autres et qu'il ya de la distance
entre les citoyens entre les habitants
et c'est la matière première pour
fabriquer une société on pourrait dire
que dans l'histoire de la géographie
dans l'histoire des espaces la
différenciation elle est extrêmement
importante parce qu'elle est une
condition de de la productivité de
l'efficacité l'urbanisation elle même
qui a commencé à dix mille ans et qui a
longtemps stagné pour ensuite prendre
son essor bah c'est bien l'idée de
mettre beaucoup de choses dans une
petite étendue sur une petite surface et
grâce à ça d'obtenir plus de relation
plus d'interactions donc s'il n'y avait
pas de différenciation ce qu'il ya
parfois ce fantasme de dire que tout
devrait être pareil que l'harmonie du
territoire ça serait cueillette tout
d'un petit peu partout et en fait donc
ça serait contraire à l'idée
d'urbanisation donc en fait la
différenciation elle est fondamentale
pour que l'espace joue son rôle
productive vous diriez la même chose
laurent davezies mobiliserait dürckheim
qui dira pas la même chose inquiété
qu'une société
société moderne société complexe où les
gens sont différents et ont besoin les
uns des autres et ça rompt avec la
tradition d'une société antérieur à
celui du village étaient
tristes originale façon où il y avait
effectivement tout le monde est pareil
et tout le monde est assigné à des
tâches ça ça ne bouge jamais ça changera
les années la société de joris du clem
d'une société qui fonctionne c'est
souhaité les gens sont différents alors
il ya beaucoup de gens qui prônent quand
même le génie tu es à 2022
sont des gens très différents qui ont
des intérêts différents mais qui ont
besoin d'être ensemble c'est la
solidarité organique dont nous parle
dürckheim donc ça va c'est ce que vient
de dire que c'est nécessaire la
diversité c'est pas une caractéristique
c'est pas une couleur c'est pas un
objectif c'est le moteur de nos sociétés
mais la diversité gérard longuet s'est
marié l'histoire et la géographie sur un
territoire c'est ça qui lui dans ce sens
alors y est l'histoire oui il ya la
géographie incontestablement et la
technologie je crois qu'il vaut vraiment
insister sur les modes de production
nous avons pendant des siècles lutter
contre la faim et l'agriculteur avait
une position absolument dominante y
compris en france pratiquement jusqu'aux
années 1950
l'industrie des ions les trente
glorieuses c'est le passage d'une main
d'oeuvre agricole peu productive vers
des activités industrielles de
consommation de masse très productif de
l'industrie existait avant les années 50
évidemment mais l'industrie de masse à
développer s'est développé avec les
années 50 avec des relations et le
territoire qui était liée strictement la
main d'oeuvre
l'industrialisation de la vallée de la
seine les régions de la bretagne avec
l'automobile
c'est parce qu'il y avait la main
d'oeuvre disponible et qu'il fallait
utiliser quand on est passé dans les
années allaient 80 du verre la
tertiarisation les grandes villes ont
changé vous aviez raison madame de dire
que dans les grandes villes il ya des
riches à payer des pauvres il ya des
très riches aussi d'ailleurs il ya des
classes moyennes il ya des pauvres vient
surtout de l'activité c'est à dire qu'il
y à du développement alors que dans une
autre partie de la france celle que je
connais assez bien comme élu vous avez
la fin d'un mode de production
l'agriculteur est très présente sur le
territoire mais suscite beaucoup moins
d'activité ou en tous les cas d'activité
direct des activités mais beaucoup moins
d'activités direct et surtout toute
l'industrie de consommation
c'est au plan mandel spécialisées y
compte alors en france un peu en europe
pas mal dans le monde beaucoup et donc
l'industrie qui
jusque dans les années 50-60 quadriller
le territoire français a sévi des essais
pas vidé d'une décision volontaire mais
mais tout simplement par la compétition
et la concurrence des territoires
industriels ceux qui s'en sont mieux
sortis ce sont sans doute les métropoles
avec en effet des diversités de
situation extraordinairement forte parce
que les métropoles c'est l'endroit où il
ya l'argent ça veut dire c'est l'endroit
où le foncier est cher ou l'immobilier
cher et où les gens qui ne sont pas
riches parce que le rôle économique ne
permet pas de l'être et bien seront
rejetées à l'extérieur donc en effet les
métropoles se développent et ont sans
doute plus de problème que le monde
rural qui est plus confortable mais quel
sentiment de ne pas avoir d'avenir alors
on est en train de dire que finalement
il ya une culture des territoires et mp
skins est ce que votre avis c'est pas un
peu utopique parce que dans notre
période de mondialisation
les traditions s'estompent les modes de
vie s'uniformise qu'est-ce qui vous et
cette culture des territoires dont nous
essayons à travers le langage de la
faire revivre mais comment vous la voyez
je crois qu'elle se révèle
particulièrement en ce moment face aux
nouveaux défis y que sont la transition
écologique mais aussi la transition
économique on a parlé de
désindustrialisation à l'instant il faut
savoir que le bassin minier est est un
territoire riche en france il ya encore
une centaine d'années et donc on bascule
aussi par des effets de transition
fortwo rapide ou transformation du monde
économique des territoires d'un côté à
l'autre en fait et donc je le disais les
questions qui sont posées par les défis
environnementaux aujourd'hui nous révèle
particulièrement les différences entre
les territoires notamment face à ces
défis alors évidemment des différences
géographiques avant d'arriver aux
différences culturelles mais c'est le
littoral n'est pas affectés de la même
manière évidemment par les questions
climatiques ou la montagne que des
territoires plus urbain mais des
territoires agricoles par exemple pour
être très fortement frappée par les
questions de pénurie d'eau non qu'on on
va être face à une différenciation forte
de la chose à régler par rapport à cette
question environnementale alors député
brad de lexus pour poser des problèmes
qui vont venir oui mais il commence des
habits sont certainement sur les
sociétés mais ils n'ont pas encore
modifié les comportements non et je
pense que c'est une manière de révéler
finalement à la diversité de ses
territoires et je pense aussi et pour
revenir à la question culturelle que la
l'histoire industrielle justement
l'histoire ouvrière d'un territoire
l'histoire de ses ressources minières
éventuellement sont des éléments forts
aussi de la culture des territoires et
est justement face à ces nouveaux défis
on voit bien qu'ils n'ont pas tous la
même chance d'y arriver je vous parlais
de l'axé seine la vallée de la seine qui
est la vallée l'automobile du pétrole
etc on voit bien que face à cet immense
défi de la neutralité carbone mal partie
ouest carbone ils ont pas du tout le
même chemin à parcourir qu'un territoire
plus rurales qui serait auto suffisante
mais alors justement laurent davezies
vous dites il faut résister à cette idée
que c'est homogène mais est-ce qu'il
faut pas résisté pour permettre à une
culture des territoires d'émerger sinon
il ya un roulement qui aplatit tout
raisonnable entre les théories et
absolue les absolus réclament ni moyen
terme évidemment qu'il ya des identités
régionales elles existent ça ça fait
c'est pas une opinion c'est là ça ne
feriez pas les siècles moi je suis du
sud ouest
mais ça ne valait pyrénées et j'en suis
je suis très fier longtemps c'est pas ça
qui pilotent môme ma pensée mais projet
bon bon donc c'est très bien les
particularités elle même le
développement territorial il est inscrit
dans la dendre une profondeur historique
suivant les territoires qu'ils ont
subies par exemple la vda mais c'est
parfois des stations ont subi de leurs
guerres de religion ou les territoires
de l'ouest français des chouans des
vendéens et cetera
aujourd'hui et a dit que oui ce qu'ils
ont montré aujourd'hui en 2022 les
formes de développement qu on trouve
dans ce territoire là notamment a été de
mobilisation du capital localement de
banjo et
ccc la suite de cette histoire d un thé
à deux trois siècles c'est très vrai
les territoires où on a parlé du café on
a parlé de position de de talent naturel
le relief est très important que vous
êtes à 300 m 400 m d'altitude vous
n'avez pas la même production qu'à 50
mètres d'altitude et ça ce sont des
réalités vous quand vous mettez deux
vaches à l'hectare en normandie et vous
en mettez une demie sur le plateau
lorrain bah c'est pas la même densité de
population au bout d'un certain nombre
de siècle mes yeux je reviens sur le
lien il ya un aspect qui que vous avez
évoqué l'un et l'autre sens aller
jusqu'au fond il ya la fierté
territoriale et le sentiment
d'appartenir à quelque chose je prends
un exemple comme la vendée c'est les
choix qui me font penser vous avez des
territoires qui ont une l'idée qu'ils
ont quelque chose à faire et qui a une
très forte solidarité parce que les
autres ne les aiment pas et que celle
montreux voilà
c'est le vrai de l'alsace on a le
problème dans le grand est actuellement
les alsaciens ont une très forte culture
il très forte identité et ont tendance à
considérer
parfois avec raison d'ailleurs qu'ils
font les choses mieux que d'autres et
donc dans le territoire il ya l'idée
d'identité dans la métropole il n'y a
pas la même identité et puis à des
effets de classes
qu'on ne retrouve moins dans des
territoires le plus homogène des effets
de l'âge les et bourgeois envie de vivre
entre eux je vais faire préciser ce
point par jacques levy
êtes géographe on parle politiquement
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
frontières pour des raisons de sécurité
idéologique mais entre ces différents
territoires dont nous parlons c'est
plutôt des points de franchissement
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
n'ya pas quelque chose à ce niveau là
qui pose problème
bon déjà en reprenant ce que ce que vous
venez de dire tous les trois je dirais
que si on imagine un développement
endogène un territoire dont qui compte
sur ses propres forces il ya des
ressources objective par exemple avoir
une grande ville être un endroit
attractive pour les touristes mais il ya
aussi les ressources subjective et donc
l'identité peut être une ressource
l'alsace est un c'est un bon exemple
parce que en fait c'est une identité qui
est pensé par les habitants comme étant
en mouvement c'est pas une identité
régressive c'est pas une identité qui
exclut les autres et donc on voit très
bien que la force de la région alsace
c'est qu'elle a à la fois enfin jeudi la
région alsace même si elle en est plus
on est
là on vend mais met donc la force de de
l'alsace et c'est justement le fait de
combiner de façon assez efficace
c'est-à-dire que chaque éléments
concourant à l'autre une une force de
ressources objective avec une grande
ville internationale une agriculture
forte une industrie des traditions aussi
économique
favorable et aussi des ressources
supplétives qui vont plutôt dans le sens
d'une mobilisation de l'énergie des
habitants et ça ne veut pas dire que ces
nostalgiques c'est à dire ses habitants
et c'est le point que je voulais ajouter
c'est c'est le fait qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans un monde mobile c'est à dire
que les habitants de l'alsace sont pas
pour la majorité désormais les
descendants des habitants de l'alsace 10
à 200 ou 300 ans et donc les bretons si
la bretagne aujourd'hui est assez
originale c'est aussi parce qu'il y à
des bretons qui sont partis et des gens
qui sont venus breton donc il me semble
que si on veut comprendre un espace
donné il faut imaginer aussi qu'il est
fabriqué en permanence par des flux de
gens qui décident d'y habiter et qui du
coup influence nouveau je vais vous
donner la parole laurent davezies mais
je voudrais jacques levy plus d'une
précision est-ce que vous pensez que ce
qui se passe au niveau national c'est à
dire un peu en retrait sysmans de
l'ouverture les protections les
frontières et cetera ça se traduit
également au niveau du territoire où on
restera les points de franchissement
parce que des frontières s'établissent
un peu est ce qu'il ya une répercussion
je pense que dans un système politique
il faut des frontières pour savoir qui
fait quoi à qui mais c'est pas les mêmes
frontières que les frontières de la
géopolitique
c'est bien le problème qui s'est produit
en ukraine parce que en ukraine y avait
des frontières intérieures à l'union
soviétique qui n'avait pas beaucoup
d'importance surtout dans un système
totalitaire très centralisé et qui
soudain on en a eu une autre quand le
crâne est devenu
un pays indépendant
nous dans la société européenne j'irai à
telle quelle qu'elle se met en place il
n'ya pas y'a pas de frontières
géopolitiques interne mais en revanche
c'est vrai que le fait justement d'avoir
une identité par exemple quand on est
breton c'est de dire bah les décisions
que je prends les engagements que je
prends en tant que citoyen de la
bretagne c'est assez logique qu'elle ait
un impact sur les bretons et pas
forcément sur les lorrains donc
l'existence de sociétés politique où les
citoyens sont à la fois ceux qui
prennent les décisions et ceux à qui
s'applique les décisions induisent quand
même l'intérêt de frontières
relativement claires même si en effet
elles peuvent être facilement franchie
oui laurent
il faut y aller doucement dans l'absolu
entités locales régionales parce que
c'est ça qui donne les résultats que mon
voile en italie d'une heure barcelone
flamands
étaient rares dans la trame de pays dans
le monde en europe et dans le monde on
en a effectué dans cette montée de de
régionalisme de demandes d'autonomie
wanda devant d'indépendance ya ces de
90% des conflits dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui sont les conflits intra
nationaux
et pas dix huit frontières
internationales 90% si on veut te passer
aujourd'hui vers un peu modifié
la parole répondirent d'orpheline choix
parce que c'est là c'est une boîte de
pandore c'est sûr là est la seule vraie
frontière qui une réalité c'est la
frontière nationale
c'est le seul objectif qu'est ce que
c'est le périmètre à l'interdît qu'elle
s'exerce et solidarité
60% du pin
dans les dépenses publiques et sociales
la frontière europe avec 2 c'est une
fiction c'est un artefact ses sympathies
je veux tu es pour maastricht et tous
ses biens en europe la vraie frontière
internationale les frontières internes
région on n'en veut pas
excusez moi la majorité des rennais sont
bretons la minorité la majorité des
parisiens ne sont pas francs il ya
des métropoles vont être heureux de
repartir c'est par une grande métropole
mondiale cd melting-pot c'est moi je
parle des métropoles en culottes courtes
dans un livre c'est là les petites
métropole qui veulent se la joue et
indépendante mais qui sont des petites
joue dans la cour des petites ça c'est
des gens qui veulent fabriquer des
frontières à l'intérieur c'est
extrêmement dangereux discutable la
seule vraie frontière russe a entendu
gérard lambert ce que je vais dire c'est
que depuis le début je parle des
territoires de la république française
parce que vous avez tout à fait raison
90% des conflits on voit bien d'ailleurs
dans l'actualité c'est l'héritage de
frontières qui ne sont pas acceptés
d'ailleurs c'était le cas des états unis
avec le nord et le sud au 19ème siècle
c'est le cas à l'interrogation
permanente des frontières héritées de la
décolonisation
est-ce qu'on l'égard des soins gardent
en général on les garde pour avoir la
paix apparente mais elle ne règle pas
tout tant s'en faut et là en france on a
une chance c'est qu'au fond on accepte
assez bien nos frontières on a payé très
cher
c'est la tranchée des baïonnettes qui a
fait l'unité française le jour un
régiment de chouans était décimée à
verdun
on s'est dit qu'on était dans la même
barque et puis on a eu les mêmes ennuis
avec les mêmes adversaires ça veut pas
dire qu'il n'y ait pas d identité à ces
différentes et qui sont liées à la
religion vous avez raison les les pays
contestataire les cathares sont devenus
ensuite protestants et ont toujours été
contre le pouvoir il était d'ailleurs
républicain sous l'empiré et
bonapartiste sous la république c'était
des gens très particulier donc il y a
des différences culturelles tu en as
beau mais parce que les gens bougent
plus et surtout parce que l'information
je vous raconte investissement
l'information est national voire
international
là la ligne de partage linguistique
entre le par les romans il parlait
germanique en lorraine qui d'ailleurs
est la même aux pays bas c'est le traité
le serment de strasbourg 2 842 entre 840
de
1957 lignes linguistiques n'a pas changé
depuis 1950 elle a disparu parce que il
y a à travers mais les territoires entre
eux unis dans une unicité d'information
et demain que le numérique c'est encore
plus accentuée et donc la notion de
territoire survie parce que les gens
veulent se raccrocher à quelque chose et
en même temps toute la technique aboutie
au brassage
[Musique]
à l'oreillette peskine vais vous
demander un diagnostic les lois de
décentralisation de
2014-2015 relative à la création de
grandes régions et à une modernisation
territoriales sont diversement appréciés
pour les as le ruissellement a passé
pour d'autres ça accru les inégalités
quel diagnostic vous faites entre ces
deux sens c'est une période des lois de
décentralisation qui a valorisé le
binôme en grande région donc région à
l'échelle européenne et métropole
justement comme capitale régionale alors
parfois il ya deux capitales dans la
même région ce qui a pu poser quelques
problèmes comme toulouse et montpellier
pour la grande région d'occitanie ou
dans la brèche grand test on se retrouve
avec trois métropoles mais enfin il ya
quand même une qui apprend un peu le
rang de capitale régionale et c'était
vraiment l'aboutissement d'un modèle de
pensée un peu libérale on peut le dire
de management des territoires avec en
gros un chef qui ruisselle enfin en tout
cas un poste de commandement qui
ruisselle sur son territoire est une
organisation territoriale l'échelle
régionale qui permet d'assurer les
solidarités avait complémentarité en
plus de celles qui sont déjà assurés par
les péréquation nationale et ce modèle a
finalement assez vite craquelé pour
plein de raisons d'abord les grandes
régions sont un peu trop grande pour
certaines elles ont justement plusieurs
identités culturelles c'est notamment le
cas de l'alsace lorraine enfin du grand
test on va dire c'est un peu le cas un
peu moins mais un peu le cas de
l'occitanie mais qui reste quand même
une région qui a une histoire plus
longue donc il peut se trouver une
identité et c'est le cas de la nouvelle
aquitaine qui réunit du limousin du
poitou charentes et l'aquitaine et donc
ça a créé une distance et une
technicisation finalement de ces deux
segments de région qui a plutôt été en
défaveur d'un rapprochement avec le
citoyen et de la même manière la
métropole se sont trouvés avec une
mission nouvelle affirmation de
métropole dit la loi de commandeur d'un
territoire qu'elle ne connaissait pas si
bien que ça et donc elle se sont
confrontés à leurs réancrage dans ce
territoire lalande oui mais quel
avantage c'est quel avantage alors avoir
fait cette chose là je suis passionné là
pour évaluer la qualité de ces lois de
décentralisation il y avait une logique
comme toutes les lois français de
décentralisation d'organiser et de
redonner des compétences uniques à
chacun de chacune des strates
territoriales ça n'a évidemment pas eu
cet effet au contraire même je dirais
que les régions se sont peut être plus
tôt comme le dit j'ai le politiste
gilles pinson transformer quasiment en
agence de l'état pour le développement
économique elle peine beaucoup à jouer
leur rôle d'aménagement du territoire
qui échoit plutôt aux intercommunalités
et justement et en métropole et
finalement les métropoles qui se sent
elle même affirmé au départ et on
cherchait ce statut de capitale
régionale se retrouve confronté à des
mouvements très fort anti métropolitain
dans l'idée qu'elles auraient phagocyter
comme on le disait tout à l'heure les
emplois les activités l'intelligence au
sens de l'économie de la connaissance de
la recherche du développement de
l'université et c'est au détriment
d'autres villes dont on a peu parlé
jusque là qui sont ces pôles d'équilibré
on va en parler des villes voyage mais
gérard longuet est-ce que vous pensez
que cette décentralisation qui aboutit à
ces grandes régions c'était une manière
de copié voire de singer ce qui ce qui
existe en allemagne avec les länder et
finalement avec une réussite mitigée
réussite mitigée il ya des des unités
qui fonctionne bien je requiers la
normandie a retrouvé son unité et les
normands sont plutôt contents même s'il
y a une bipolarité en manquant le grand
s à du mal et les champenois les
lorrains sont pas mécontents mais semble
qu'ils ne sont pas aimés des alsaciens
qui m'auront qui le disent assez
curieusement rhône alpes auvergne
rhône-alpes a l'air de marcher peut-être
la paire l'énergie du président y est
pour quelque chose
la grande à quai la nouvelle aquitaine
elle est quand même un petit peu grande
et je lisais raffarin parce qu'on
parlait ces régions génie mais tu veux
faire des grandes régions mais avec deux
tgv parce que la technique ça joue
beaucoup sur le territoire si vous
voulez le cheval le vélo la voiture le
chemin de fer le tgv ça fait d'autre ça
dessine d'autres territoires et
aujourd'hui il est plus facile en
général d'aller à paris grâce au tgv où
que vous soyez dans une région que
d'aller à la capitale régionale quand je
suis à bar-le-duc je suis à une heure de
tgv de paris est à deux heures de
strasbourg donc si j'ai besoin comme
responsable d'avoir un interlocuteur
compétent je fais à paris je sûr de le
trouver si je vais à strasbourg je vais
rencontrer un directeur de banque qui me
dira votre votre projet est intéressant
je vais en parler à paris bon je vais
directement paris alors qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
clay vibre laurent davezies moi je sais
pas mais aussi si j'étais président de
la république je vais l'avoir formé
alors il faut y aller
je ferai une femme ça détonne un peu au
hasard comme ça je suis sûr que ça a
marché parce qu'après tout les personnes
politiques dès lors qu'ils vont se
présenter aux élections sur ses nouveaux
périmètres regarder la série mondiale et
vous avez le projet vous êtes élu vous
êtes élu dans grant est surtout pas dire
le grand test arrivera lire dire c'est
une région excusez moi pour remettre
votre technique à la con il n'y a que
les élus qu'ils le pensent les élus
régionaux
élus ne pouvais pas faire quand les gars
disent pas si vous avez à sur un
territoire que que vous ne reconnaissez
pas forcément c'est après une
dévaluation moi j'entends partout des
élus dire ouais la région c'est pas si
mal acquis si les entrées le matin
libération donne une carte l'après-midi
le monde dans une autre journal fait
très bien fait sur un coin de table à la
faire je sais que j'étais un électeur de
françois hollande
se descendent à 100 degrés en plus mais
s'était fait n'importe comment et en
plus ça occupe un espace énorme dans les
discussions alors qu'en fait c'était
petit younes qu'en terme de pouvoir
ariza general que l'odeur landais rien
puissance économique financière c'est
colossal
lalande il faut dire que
les mises sur ce point finances oui je
continue dans l'esprit de ce que vient
de dire laurent davezies c'est à dire
que en fait le portrait que faisait
hélène peskine de la réforme régionale
on est sur un plan discursif en fait il
s'est pas passé grand-chose globalement
parce que si on regarde les 56 % de
fibres il passe par l'état y en a plus
que 12% qui passent dans l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales et sur ces
12 % il y en a une partie infime qui va
aux régions et ça ça n'a pas changé par
la réforme donc ton ça n'a rien à voir
avec la taille parce que ça c'est un
problème je dirais d'auto aveuglement
d'une partie de ses pas du monde
technocratique français qui croient
qu'il ya que des grandes régions en
allemagne alors que c'est absolument
faux il ya une très grande diversité de
taille à la sarre brême ces projets des
petites enders donc c'est pas ça qui
compte c'est effectivement un système
fédéral c'est dire le fait qu' il ya un
emboîtement de territoire mais qui sont
à égalité en termes de légitimité de
souveraineté et de moyens d'assurer
cette souveraineté et qu'ensuite bas
alors il ya un projet territorial qui a
un sens qui n'est pas seulement dans les
discours électoraux entendu avec la
crise sanitaire on a beaucoup parlé de
flux de population est ce qu'à votre
avis laurent davezies ça change la donne
et est ce qui a réellement c'est plus de
population des grandes villes vers les
villes mais les agents immobiliers ont
poussé sur le moment je suis
de paris je me dis c'est terrible tout
le monde se précipite c'est la fin de la
fin des métropoles du monde part à la
campagne et tout parce que finalement on
a écouté les travailleurs moi j'ai dit
s'appeler le prix j'étais à dire je suis
vous vous avez vous
vous avez aimé les gilles et je ne vous
adorerez les télétravailleurs peut-être
que ce sont des gens qui sont entrés
dans la même situation empire alors ça
ce stade est un endroit où ils vont
aller passer trois jours par semaine à
paris à l'été frais déplacement en gros
il faut dormir deux voitures dans leurs
rangs la villa côté leur dire merci aux
yeux d'israël vous veut pas l'utiliser
c'est fini maintenant modèle transition
fâche les voitures électriques mais j'ai
pas d'argent pas
je pense que ça ne veut de paille
ça va durer un petit moment mais je
pense que les fondamentaux d'évolution
sauf s'il ya des grands changements
géopolitiques ou qui peuvent pas le
savoir ce que sera le rendez vous depuis
20 ans on a eu que d'expliquer qu'il
tombait sur la figure la seule période
un peu normale c'est 2016 2019 un autre
mandat que des fusées mois des gros
emmerdements lyon si on a une continuité
à mon avis on reviendra au système
metropolit à l'emploi se développe de
façon extrêmement fortes dans les temps
les plus grands centres des drivers aux
plus grands pôles d'emploi le une
collation entre taille du marché de
l'emploi et les dynamiques de ce marché
de l'emploi qui est arithmétique il est
important restera et ce rêve de j'habite
à la campagne se peut virer au cauchemar
et quand je vois tous ces gens utiliser
ma c'est vachement bien qui poussent à
la roue des jeunes gens à faire ça ça va
créer je répète on refera des finales
nba skin feu de paille d'un côté mais
vous vous défendez le fait que ces
petites villes
revivre
et qu'il y a quelque chose de possible
alors en fait il faut regarder cette
question depuis l'origine et depuis la
demi b aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a
travaillé sur cette question d'accent
durban on a essayé de l'objective et
avec des chiffres des données qui sont
notamment celles des agences
immobilières en ligne qui nous montre
les flux de transactions il n'y a pas du
tout à un exode urbain massif des
centre-ville vers les autres territoires
qui serait ruraux pas du tout et on
n'est pas du tout dans le mouvement
inverse de l'exode rural des années 50
on en est très très loin et les bills
sont très attractives encore aujourd'hui
les centres villes les hypercentres un
peu moins et pourquoi pas seulement à
cause du covin même si le confinement a
eu un gros effet sur le ressenti de
confort d'aller dans les centres villes
mais parce qu'il a fait suite à des pics
de pollution à des crises de transport à
des grèves des poubelles et c'est du
terrorisme dont certaines des grandes
métropoles françaises et pas seulement
paris est donc en fait on est on sort de
dix ans de crises successives des
métropoles notamment dit l'hyper centre
de métropole qu'il faut que les gens on
voit là le souhait de s'éloigner alors
en général ce qu'on constate dans ces
chiffres c'est que c'est plutôt du
desserrement on sort de l'hyper centre
pour aller un peu plus loin dans la
périphérie avec l'idée que effectivement
si on n'est pas obligé d'aller tous les
jours sur son lieu de travail on peut
gérer mieux la difficulté la distance en
transport donc cette catégorie là de
personnes qui sont qui ont quitté le
centre-ville sont plutôt aller un peu
plus loin dans la métropole va encore
plus loin quand on est à paris on se
retrouve parfois à 100 km dans les
colonnes de villes moyennes qui sont
effectivement au delà de l'île de france
mais par ailleurs on constate d'autre
chose c'est que c'est un public très
particulier qui fait cette transaction
immobilière et en particulier des gens
très riches c'est des gens aisés très
riche au relativement riche pour les
moyens s'acheter une deuxième maison
quand ils en ont déjà une ou voir une
première mais de rester locataire d'un
logement dans l'hyper centre et donc
d'avoir deux voire trois résidences et
donc la difficulté quand on regarde du
côté de la destination ça peut changer
assez radicalement 3 4 10 famille dans
une ville moyenne ou petite la
sociologie locale le prix de
l'immobilier et c'est là qu'il ya des
vraies tensions puisque on est face à
des ménages qui ont les moyens déchets
rapidement et relativement un prix
relativement élevé à peine en visitant
du des des maisons souvent sienne ou des
terrains en se disant ça sera toujours
quelque chose pour l'avenir notamment
sur le confinement revenez parce qu'il
ya aussi un peu cette inquiétude voire
effondrement ou d'une situation qui
pourrait devenir alors là motif de
précaution évident les gens pensaient
pas l'inflation élevée à 6 moi je dis ça
mais attention l'inflation il ya un
motif de précaution ans histoire des
achats de biens et les gens sont pas
idiots ils ont des bons prix que quoi
qu'il en coûte toujours s'agira se payer
si vous avez des économies en argent
liquide aujourd'hui à la banque c'est
l'intérêt les transformer en pierre un
effet social pour terminer qui est
important localement ça dans ces
territoires d'accueil même si
quantitativement s'est pas beaucoup de
gens ça exclut de fait du logement des
gens qui avaient l'habitude des sujets
plus facilement alors
avec vous gérard longuet doit aborder
une question qui vous tient à coeur la
réindustrialisation on parle beaucoup de
ré industrialisation mon lit à des
budgets très importants qui sont
consacrés à ça dans le domaine des
innovations dans le domaine du nucléaire
dans le domaine dans des domaines de la
pharmacie etc
cette ré industrialisation a besoin d
espace
elle a besoin de main d'oeuvre est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une
réindustrialisation va permettre de
réhabiliter les petits territoires et de
corriger un peu c'est infractuosités
territoriale crois que ça va être très
difficile
parce que c'est lié ce que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure au marché du travail et
un employeur aujourd'hui ne veut plus
être mono employeurs l'employeur
exclusive d'un petit bassin ce qu'a
accepté très bien au contraire ce que
recherchaient les patrons d'entreprises
utilisent le terme patron pour bien
rappelé que c'était le patronat qui
voulait être en général le principal
employeur d'une petite ville pour ne pas
avoir de concurrence salariale peut pas
avoir deux et pour gérer le climat
social dès que vous avez plusieurs
entreprises ça devient beaucoup plus
compliqué
ce que le personnel peut changer il ya
des concurrences des rivalités des
conflits des confrontations
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas un
employeur veut être dans un grand bassin
d'emploi pour trouver du personnel et
pour le cas échéant se séparer de son
personnel sans que ce soit un drame et
j'ajoute que les couples travaillent les
femmes ont toujours travaillé mais pas
comme salarié matin travaillé comme
salarié des hommes travaille aussi comme
salarié quand vous avez un petit bassin
d'emploi c'est très difficile de trouver
simultanément le même niveau de
qualification pour les deux conjoints et
donc la réindustrialisation je suis
évidemment je ne rêve que de cela mais
elle se heurte à deux problèmes le
premier je viens d'évoquer le bassin
d'emploi alors grâce à l'automobile mais
en faible densité de population vous est
large et celle bassin d'emploi et pour
prendre un mot savant que j'ai découvert
il ya pas longtemps je vais te cuistre
les courbes iso crown des commandes et
définissent le bassin d'emploi
dans mon département de la meuse qui est
un département rural tous les villages
qui sont à moins de 45 minutes en auto
mobile donnons ci se développe pourquoi
parce qu'il ya soit des jeunes qui
veulent une maison avec de l'espace et
la nature pour leurs enfants soient des
vieux qui préparent leur retraite et qui
acceptent leurs enfants sont déjà
autonome et qui habite plus loin parce
que c'est en même temps leur résidence
secondaire est souvent l'un des deux
conjoints a cessé de travailler mais
l'industrie a le vrai problème n'est pas
celui là c'est qu'il faut des chefs
d'entreprise c'est à dire des gens qui
aient envie de gagner de l'argent en
prenant des risques
c'est pas très commun aujourd'hui
autre point de vue laurent david orr
réindustrialisation pour
tout le village à 100 ce qui me gêne
dans le mooré industrie
réindustrialisation c'est le mort et qui
laisse penser que c'est le retour à
quelque chose qui existait avant en fait
il y aura plus évidemment les industries
de masse parce que il ya il ya par
exemple
les mouvements politiques qui s'était
fait un peu la spécialité de défendre le
monde ouvrier qui réclame la
réindustrialisation mais il n'ya plus
d'ouvriers dans les usines
réindustrialiser très très peu ce sont
ce sont des des entreprises qui ont une
haute technologie avec énormément de
d'automatisation de robots etc mais
inversement ce qui est intéressant c'est
que les très vrai ce que vous dites et
ça suppose peu d'unité pour un très
grand marché je moi j'adore la mécanique
chacun sa passion il ya une usine dans
la banlieue de metz qui fait tous les
moteurs diesel alors c'est pas un avenir
flou mais tous les moteurs diesel de
france bon là
que je voulais juste des gens qui
vérifient que inversement ce qui est
intéressant aujourd'hui c'est qu'il peut
y avoir plein d'endroits comme comme
l'ensemble du territoire est très bien
connecté à lui même et au reste du monde
en fait il ya plein d'endroits par
exemple prêter renom il ya une
entreprise de de deux prothèses
médicales qui a surgi presque de nulle
part parce qu'il y avait une des
conditions locales
pionner par le sujet complexe mais en
fait ça peut marcher donc en fait ça qui
est intéressant dans le processus pas
seulement pour l'industrie mais pour
l'ensemble des nouvelles activités c'est
que en fait il ya beaucoup de lieux qui
sont de bons candidats a innové
c'est à dire à ne pas seulement
reprendre des traditions qui était en
crise mais en inventer de nouvelles oui
laurent davezies jeu jacques
l'heureux réalisme le club pas non plus
pour une autre raison en fait choper
terre je
vis dans d'économistes l'homme de la
destruction créatrice on sait que nos
appareils industriels sont apparus en
mutation permanente avec des
destructions perdant dé création
permanente notre appareil statistique en
france ne nous permet pas en dépit de
demandes récurrentes de malinvaud keira
accueil gentil d'être une boîte ministre
de sortir le lycée du sort des
statistiques de destruction et création
création brute destruction brut on n'a
que des seuls de n'être donc on est
capable de dire la meuse l'an dernier
vous avez mille ouvriers cette année
vous avez 900 alors vous arracher les
cheveux en disant la sandale moi c'est
la d inspiration sauf si je relate
derrière alors moi j'ai fait cet
exercice
ça serait un peu long j'ai pas
développer ici mais moi je suis capable
de dire que le passage de 1000 à 900
c'est en fait mille moins 500 + 400 on a
créer 400 emplois est ce que c'est la
fin de l'industrie si je prends 2010 la
valeur ajoutée par emploi à 100 par la
valeur ajoutée
faire des pièces pour surtout et puis de
2007 à aujourd'hui
200 2020 on a moins 3 400 mille emplois
industriels la vérité c'est que derrière
on a moins un million un million cent en
destruction brut on a plus 700 mille
créations plus de 700 milles quand on
dit aux enfants il ya plus de bouloire
industrie laisse tomber ça sert à rien
elle en a créé sept cent mille emplois
dans la période 2016 2019 par 2006-2009
miracle partout dans les ministères
réalisation ça y est le seul art qu on a
recommencé les créations nettes
simplement avoir on avait eu d'énormes
destructions une très grosse création on
avait une très grosse création la fa se
transformer des secteurs mouret d'autres
apparaissait temps à parler à l'instant
de là un exemple et on pourrait en citer
énormément depuis 2016 2019 la pro nalco
lui dois tout les deux signataires
normal et bien à ce moment là on en crée
plus qu on en détruit on a effectivement
des dizaines de milles les créations
d'emplois
supérieures au cours des dix années
c'est moins visible parce que on moi je
souvenir de ces vallées industriels
souvent l'industrie était dans les
vallées parce qu'à l'origine ces lots
est là mais l'énergie mécanique de l'eau
donc le textile la métallurgie était
dans les vallées aujourd'hui les les
usines ont disparu plus ou moins mais le
produit existe toujours la logistique le
service la maintenance ont remplacé les
ouvriers qui étaient sur place qui
m'attend sont dispersés peu près partout
et qui interviennent en tant que de
besoin sur tel ou tel site lepoint merci
on vous a entendu russe vous versez des
services ce sommet sont des services
sont pas des ouvriers pour nous arbres
et services de l'industrie merci pardon
[Musique]
pierre rosanvallon considère que nous
régime peuvent être dits démocratiques
mais nous ne sommes pas gouvernée
démocratiquement alors nous allons
partir de là et alors ce qu'on observe
en france on pourra faire une allusion
d'ailleurs à à l'ukraine par ailleurs on
observe un peu partout et c'est une
forme d'érosion de la démocratie des
individus font l'objet d'une
classification
d'appartenance alors sommairement on a
considéré qu'il y en a qui venait de
quelque part on dit somewhere ce qui
serait de nulle part et s'adapterait par
tous animés rebond en somme y at il à
votre avis un problème de démocratie
avec les territoires et puisque vous
êtes là gérard longuet est ce que
finalement la politique ne fait pas bon
ménage avec la démocratie parce que
comme dirait notre ami jacques levy il
n'y a pas de justice sociale malgré ce
que vous avez théorisé j'appelais vie
alors gérard longuet ou jacques levy
quel finalement cette justice spatiale
ça n'existe pas c'est un problème un peu
différent la démocratie bah oui mais
pour qu'il y ait démocratie il faut
qu'il y ait aussi un jeu direct et
pourfendeur de la démocratie sont à
l'ouest et les despotes son talent est
donc or on sait bien qu'on sait bien
qu'on soit très critique sur la
démocratie mais disons que c'est grâce à
la démocratie qu'on peut l'être et par
ailleurs la france a un petit problème
spécifique c'est que c'est toujours pas
un régime parlementaire contrairement à
la grande majorité de l'europe voilà du
du monde démocratique et en particulier
de l'europe donc là vous vous dites
c'est un régime parlementaire en un
parlement il fonctionne est le régime le
plus présidentiel qu'ils soient où dans
le monde démocratique donc donc là
effectivement il ya un problème je
dirais de démocratie représentative
dont on est plus ou moins conscient mais
on n'arrive pas forcément en sortir le
avantage c'est que il ya eu des progrès
récents dans ce qu'on pourrait appeler
la surf démocratie la démocratie
participative ou interactives ou
délibérative et c'est utile je pense à
tout le monde parce que dans une des
sociétés d'individus où les gens sont
cultivés ou n'ont pas envie de se
limiter à voter une fois tous les cinq
ans c'est très important d'avoir cette
complémentarité entre la démocratie
représentative et la démocratie
interactive disent on est donc là
peut-être l'inconvénient de la france
qui a beaucoup à faire pour être un pays
normal je dirais du point de vue de la
démocratie représentative
elle a été assez à l'initiative assez
innovante et je pense que ça ça va être
un nouveau développement de la
démocratie dans l'est dans les années à
venir à condition que ce soit
correctement maîtrisés régulés que que
la relation avec le parlement soit clair
mais il me semble que là il ya beaucoup
d'avenir donc j'ai pas répondu sur la
justice spatiale mais je pense que la
démocratisation
c'est un chant légitime donc on peut
être plus démocratique que ce qu'on est
ouais alors est-ce qu'il vous pensez que
les territoires peuvent apporter ce plus
de démocratie ou qu'il nous manque
aujourd'hui avant de répondre à votre
question j'aimerais revenir sur la
relation territoire parlement il faut se
souvenir qu'on a supprimé le cumul des
mandats en france il ya quelques années
et on n'aurait peut-être pas dû en effet
parce que du coup la représentation
territoriale au parlement s'est beaucoup
affaibli et finalement les élus qui
étaient c'est un peu ma voix au sénat
évidemment que l'assemblée mais deux
mois les élus qui étaient présents à
paris sous cette forme-là du cumul du
député maire ne le sont plus et donc
qu'ils se sont mis aussi dans une forme
de retrait et même de contestation du du
parisianisme ou du bon centre du pouvoir
central qui qui est
et difficile finalement à régler
puisqu'on n'a pas de lieu où le débat se
place réellement et compris sur des
réformes qui sont liées directement aux
compétences des territoires et donc ils
ont recréé effectivement vos le lisier
des dispositifs locaux la plupart des
collectivités locales ont maintenant
lors comment sont citoyennes locales
leur parfois leur kop 21 langues locales
ou leur dispositif de concertation bien
souvent la plupart des stratégies
territoriales sont très fortement
concertée mais tout ça ça crée des blocs
territoriaux qui font pas une unité
nationale de la vision des territoires
de la parole des territoires et c'est là
je pense que ce se passe un peu le
hiatus est malheureusement alexandre
gauthier est sans doute lié à cette
décision qui est qu'il y avait du sens à
la fin du cumul des mandats c'est aussi
pour éviter la professionnalisation de
la politique et faire évoluer un petit
peu en tout cas faire bouger un petit
peu le personnel politique notamment
parlement et en fait ça a eu un effet à
mon avis délétère sur la capacité des
territoires à être représenté dans le
récit national est donc sacré des
coupures qui sont pas très saine mais
pour revenir sur la question de l'appui
de la pluie des territoires à cette
démocratie de fait les maires sur les
premiers à être concernés par les
conflits sociaux les conflits d'usagé
sont tous les jours les maires ou les
présidents d'intercommunalités confronté
à des gens qui cherchent un logement à
des conflits de voisinage au sens
territoriale du terne entre les classes
moyennes évincé dont on parlait tout à
l'heure éventuellement classes moyennes
devenu gilet jaune parce que trop
éloignés des centres métropolitains et
puis des classes créative intellectuels
qui ont d'autres besoins d'autres
attentes en termes de mobilité interne
de d'équipement d'éducation etc et donc
les justement les élus des territoires
au sens des villes et des
intercommunalités sont sans doute les
derniers à essayer de faire faire
fonctionner cette démocratie directe
avec avec les citoyens dont ils ont la
gestion comme le temps et il nous reste
très peu de temps je vous laisse dire un
mot laurent davezies re sur la
démocratie l'aude était démolie et
territoires on est absolument nu y'a pas
un vote politique sérieux de l'antiquité
grecque aujourd'hui qui nous parle de ce
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un gouvernement à
plusieurs niveaux d'administration
démocratique sanat ça n'existe pas et
dans l'histoire l'introduction du
territoire dans les processus
démocratiques a toujours été une façon
de contrôler la folie du de la
démocratie du peuple
kristen aux formes de d'athènes
seyes la création de départements on
retrouve systématiquement dont on
retrouve six arrivées au transit pas
d'histoire j'ai pas le temps de
développer à chaque fois ont
consciemment t-sql lui même le dit les
deux chambres la chambre haute la
chambre basse c'est quand même la
chambre des territoires va contrôler en
fait le territoire c'est un
stabilisateur a été cyniquement utilisé
par les pairs des différentes
constitutions depuis vingt-cinq siècles
et la vérité intrinsèquement on ne sait
pas ce qu'est la démocratie territoire
et je terminerai avec une phrase qui va
vous faire réfléchir longtemps on pense
que la somme des intérêts territoriaux
de nos territoires fait l'international
celle inverse j'ai eu un petit 10 russie
explique ce bon alors on finance et
redit en d'hermitage la république n'est
pas une addition une fédération de
mosaïques territoriales c'est un projet
collectif qui est différent des deuxième
observation il n'y a pas de justice
territoriale et c'est pas grave parce
que chacun est libre ne sommes pas à
signer un territoire après tout si on
n'est pas content du territoire évitent
on peut en changer difficile de changer
de pays parce qu'il ya la culture la
langue l'homme et de dette un territoire
on peut changer pour tout le monde ne
change pas mais même ceux qui sont
mécontents de leur territoire pourquoi
parce que il y a des adhésions qui sont
beaucoup plus profondes et qui sont
qualitatives qui ne sont pas
quantitative et je voudrais terminer
c'est par une observation politique sur
la vie parlementaire je pense que la
france est en effet le pays européen qui
n'a pas de vie parlementaire
le quinquennat et le calendrier ont tué
et j'ajoute que le scrutin majoritaire
c'est savez la formule américaine et le
gagnant prend tout à force de tout
prendre en ne représentant en réalité
que ses électeurs du premier tour c'est
à dire entre 20 et 30% des électeurs il
donne aux 70% autres le sentiment d'être
extérieure à la vie locale merci à leur
avance un vrai problème constitué un
dernier mot sur la justice spatiale sur
l'aspect démocratique de la justice
spatiale oui nature qui manquent à
laurent davezies ça s'appelle le
fédéralisme et je pense que du poulet et
jacques levy pour elle peut-être piocher
là dedans mais la justice partiale c'est
quoi la justice spatiale ça se définit
pas a priori c'est à vos citoyens de
dire qu'est ce qu'un espace juste ils
ont des idées dans ta fête vous avez un
critère est ce que les est ce que les
gens quittent leur territoire ou est ce
qu'il le garde s'il le garde c'est
qu'ils ont des raisons profondes de
vouloir le garder rien ne les y oblige
oui
ce qui est sorti il a tout récemment sur
les effets de la hausse des prix du
carburant sur les territoires est très
intéressante parce qu'elle montre que
justement c'est la couronne des
métropoles qui a le plus subi la hausse
des prix du carburant qui est très
significative en gros c'est à 40
kilomètres des centres des métropoles
que les gens sont le plus fortement
touché oui ce qu'ils font des
allers-retours pour les loyers et donc
on voit bien que toutes les questions de
justice spatiale est là elle est à
géométrie variable en fonction du
contexte en fonction des questions qu'on
se pose et la manière dont on se réfère
à l'autre comme étant plus enfin plus
avantagés disons plus privilégiés que
c'est aussi la conséquence de leur choix
c'est ce que je suis dernier mot et les
vies parce que nous arrivons à la ronde
a été mis sur et la justice spatiale est
l'effet à la fois de politique publique
et aussi de choix c'est à dire que
personne n'a été déporté dans le
périurbain du mans
merci beaucoup comparé tout le prix de
l'immobilier merci madame merci
messieurs alors je vais vous présenter
une brève bibliographie
alors jacques levy vous avez publié avec
jean nicolas fauci et anne povos
théorie de la justice spatiale nous en
avons parlé justement bonbons à la
géographie du juste et de l'injuste
voilà en somme vous appliquer
aux territoires des questions de vertus
ou des questions de philosophie qu en
quelque sorte c'est pour réhabiliter le
territoire oui on s'aperçoit que si on
approche la justice par le territoire on
découvre aussi des choses intéressantes
sur la justice en général c'est pas
simplement l'application de règles on
rencontre aussi on élargit je dirais la
notion de justice où le débat sur la
justice je rappelle que vous avez
également publié géographie du politique
laurent davezies alors vous avez publié
le nouvel égoïsme territoriales en deux
mots c'est quoi le nouvel égoïsme
territoriales c'est la fragmentation des
nations et des régions riches ici on
commence aujourd'hui a pu voir payer
pour les régions pauvres je vois du jeu
rapide c'est ce qui s'est passé par
exemple au moment où la grèce était en
déficit et que leurs noms n'ont pas
cessé l'italie du nord où il était plus
payer pour le sud pour laquelle et
flamands qui fait peser pour les wallons
c'est les allemands les écossais qui
croient qu'ils sont plus riches que le
royaume uni qui lui plaît pour l'heure
qu'ils sont plus pauvres donc c'est un
mouvement quasiment séparatiste oui la
catalogne c'est la cata beyala savoir
qu'ils honorent alsacien dirai pas que
je rappelle également que vous avez
publié laurent davezies l'état toujours
soutenu ces territoires où plus
récemment le couple récemment mais vous
y croyez l'état toujours je te le disais
le livre où en est votre avis et les
skins bah oui mais à coups de vivre on a
financé c'est à dire qu'on a retiré tout
pouvoir fiscal le territoire et on les
nourrit de subventions jouant des
dotations terrible pour des futurs
c'est pour eux on leur donne
effectivement des compétences sont nécé
pour eux et on les aliments de
financièrement pour le revenu des
ménages augmente l'emploi alors et aides
mais ce qui nous vous avez vous dirigez
le puca en deux mots vous allez dire ce
que ses fans et en même temps vous
publier une série de publications
là nous en avons une olivier bouba-olga
pour un nouveau récit territoriales deux
mots sur le puca et deux mots sur la
collection que vous dirigez au celle du
puca alors ça s'appelle le plan
urbanisme construction architecture
cédant fait un espèce de think tank de
l'état qui est interministériel écologie
est un territoire culture au titre de
l'architecturé enseignement supérieur et
recherche qui a pour mission de diffuser
des connaissances sur le fonctionnement
urbain est donc de plus en plus sur les
stratégies de territoire et donc cette
collection elle est éditée par la
plateforme d'observation des projets et
stratégies urbaines qui est un des
programmes du puca qui s'intéresse aux
villes aux petites villes d'une part et
aux métropoles d'autre part et qui
compare des stratégies justement avec
l'aide de chercheurs essaient de cet
ouvrage de olivier bouba-olga il parle
justement des petites villes et des
territoires en particulier de l'ouest
français qui bien qu'il ne soit pas
mettre au pot lisez pas la grande ville
c'est poitiers en gros ils sont capables
de se défendre dans la compétition
mondiale et donc il parle d'une espèce
de de décentrage du regard c'est à dire
qu'on n'est pas forcément drogué à la
métropolisation peut aussi faire du
développement quand on est hors de
métropole merci vous aux puits n'est pas
gérard longuet pour deux mots pas plus
non je pense que les la tertiarisation
le l'élévation du niveau de compétence
de qualification
l'exigence d'avoir un marché d'emploi
riche pour des gens formés favorise
quand même durablement
les grandes métropoles et quand on est à
poitiers c'est quand même plus difficile
que quand on est à nantes ou à paris
merci madame parent et à d'autres
communes alors si madame merci messieurs
je voudrais remercier l'équipe d'être cp
vous laisser avec cette pensée de daniel
cohen le terme de ma s'applique à des
gens qui ne peuvent s'intégrer dans
aucune organisation
fondée sur l'intérêt commun écoutez
c'est un cette question de masse
justement au lieu de parler de
population c'est une question que nous
aborderons dans d'autres émissions sur
les territoires pour montrer qu'un
territoire c'est aussi les populations
qu'ils habitent et qui le vert dissocie
et qui permettent une activité
territoriales merci
[Musique]